this video is sponsored by the american
lung cancer screening initiative
lung cancer is the leading cause of
cancer-related death in the world
but lung cancer screening can save lives
click the link below to learn more
every time you smoke a cigarette toxic
gases
pass into your lungs then into your
bloodstream
where they spread to every organ in your
body
a cigarette is made using the tobacco
leaf
which contains nicotine and a variety of
other compounds
as the tobacco and compounds burn they
release
thousands of dangerous chemicals
including over 40 known to cause cancer
cigarette smoke contains the poisonous
gases carbon monoxide and
nitrogen oxide as well as trace amounts
of cancer-causing radioactive particles
all forms of tobacco are dangerous
including cigars
pipes and smokeless tobacco such as
chewing tobacco and snuff
nicotine is an addictive chemical in
tobacco
after you inhale tobacco smoke nicotine
flows through the bloodstream
to your brain where it induces a
pleasurable feeling
when you repeatedly expose your brain to
nicotine
it becomes desensitized making you crave
more and more nicotine just to feel
normal
smoking causes death people who smoke
typically die at an earlier age than
non-smokers
in fact one of every five deaths in the
united states
is linked to cigarette smoking
if you smoke your risk of major health
problems
increases dramatically including heart
disease
heart attack stroke lung cancer
and death from chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease
causes cardiovascular disease
when nicotine flows through your adrenal
glands
it stimulates the release of epinephrine
a hormone that raises your blood
pressure
in addition nicotine and carbon monoxide
can damage the lining of the inner walls
in your arteries
fatty deposits called plaque can build
up at these injury sites
and become large enough to narrow the
arteries
and severely reduce blood flow resulting
in a condition
called atherosclerosis
in coronary artery disease
atherosclerosis
narrows the arteries that supply the
heart
which reduces the supply of oxygen to
your heart muscle
increasing your risk for a heart attack
smoking also raises your risk for blood
clots
because it causes platelets in your
blood to clump together
smoking increases your risk for
peripheral vascular disease in which
atherosclerotic plaques
block the large arteries in your arms
and legs
smoking can also cause an abdominal
aortic aneurysm
which is a swelling or weakening of your
aorta where it runs through your abdomen
smoking damages two main parts of your
lungs
your airways also called bronchial tubes
and small air sacs called alveoli
with each breath air travels down your
windpipe
called the trachea and enters your lungs
through your bronchial tubes
air then moves into thousands of tiny
alveoli
where oxygen from the air moves into
your bloodstream
and the waste product carbon dioxide
moves out of your bloodstream
tiny hair-like projections called cilia
line your bronchial tubes and sweep
harmful substances
out of your lungs
cigarette smoke irritates the lining of
your bronchial tubes
causing them to swell and make mucus
cigarette smoke also slows the movement
of your cilia
causing some of the smoke and mucus to
stay in your lungs
while you are sleeping some of the cilia
recover
and start pushing more pollutants and
mucus
out of your lungs when you wake up
your body attempts to expel this
material by coughing repeatedly
a condition known as smoker's cough
over time chronic bronchitis develops as
your cilia stop
working your airways become clogged with
scars and
mucus and breathing becomes difficult
your lungs are now more vulnerable to
further disease
cigarette smoke also damages your
alveoli
making it harder for oxygen and carbon
dioxide
to exchange with your blood over time
so little oxygen can reach your blood
that you may develop
emphysema a condition in which you must
gasp for every breath
and wear an oxygen tube under your nose
in order to breathe
chronic bronchitis and emphysema are
collectively called
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease or
copd
copd is a gradual loss of the ability to
breathe
for which there is no cure
cigarette smoke contains at least 40
cancer-causing substances
called carcinogens including cyanide
formaldehyde benzene and ammonia
in your body healthy cells grow make new
cells then die genetic material
inside each cell called dna directs this
process
if you smoke toxic chemicals
can damage the dna in your healthy cells
as a result your damaged cells create
new
unhealthy cells which grow out of
control
and may spread to other parts of your
body
the most common cancer in the world is
lung cancer
with over a million new cases diagnosed
every year
harmful chemicals in cigarettes can
cause cancer in other parts of your body
such as in the blood and bone marrow
mouth larynx
throat esophagus
stomach pancreas
kidney bladder
uterus and cervix
smoking can cause infertility in both
men and women
if a woman is pregnant and smokes during
pregnancy
she exposes her baby to the cigarette's
poisonous chemicals
causing a greater risk of low birth
weight
miscarriage pre-term delivery
stillbirth infant death
and sudden infant death syndrome
smoking is also dangerous if a mother is
breastfeeding
nicotine passes to the baby through
breast milk
and can cause restlessness rapid
heartbeat
vomiting interrupted sleep
or diarrhea
other health effects of smoking include
low bone density and increased risk for
hip fracture among women
gum disease often leading to tooth loss
and surgery
immune system dysfunction and delayed
wound healing
and sexual impotence in men